I'm Armenian born and raised in Iran
right I've done very well for myself
I've made a few hundred million dollars
okay but if I go sit down with my mom
who's Armenian she'll talk about one of
her friend's daughters that got a
four-year degree and I don't have a
four-year degree so to her success is a
four-year degree what is the difference
between a person who goes to Harvard
they're making 130 a year versus a
person who went to a community college
and builts a business that sells it for
1.2 billion in the eyes of an educator
Harvard gets more credibility in the
eyes of a doer of course you're going to
look at the guy that's generated Revenue